mean is a javascript-based software
stack for creating dynamic web pages and
online applications
mean application can be developed in one
language for both server-side and
client-side execution because all
components of mean stack support
javascript programming
hello everyone and welcome to simply
learn's youtube channel
i hope you are doing well
today we will be taking you through the
mean stack full course this means stack
full course is designed to help you
understand the most widely used concepts
of mongodb angularjs express.js and
node.js in an exciting manner
in mean stack we use angular framework
you can also go for react full course
after learning angular the link for
react full course and mean stack full
course will be in the description box
in this full course you will also learn
about mongodb
how to install and use the database
after we will also learn about node and
express in detail and then angular
in the end of this full course you will
be able to understand and deploy mean
stack
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on
programming videos so if you are a
programmer and want to learn something
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and press the bell icon
to never miss any update from simply
learn so without further ado let's begin
and see what's in it for you
first
we will see the introduction to this
full course and then we'll see what is
mongodb after that we'll see comparison
between mongodb and mysql moving ahead
we'll see what is express.js after that
we'll see get in post methods in
express.js after that we'll see what is
middleware
after that we'll see how to connect
slideside to the server side moving
ahead we'll see what is angularjs
features of angularjs and the companies
that are using angularjs moving ahead
we'll see how to install node.js on a
windows machine and we'll see overview
of a node.js
after that
we'll see what is node.js npm moving
ahead we'll see how to build node.js
rest api using node.js
and in last we'll see how to connect
node.js to mongodb
so let's start this course
over to our training expert
so what exactly is mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents
it offers developers the flexibility to
work with evolving data models since
it's document based mongodb allows
embedded documents arrays and represents
complex hierarchical relationships using
a single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like sql why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation
native aggregation allows its users to
extract and transform data from mongodb
and either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard balancer
[Music]
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is json now json is widely used
across the web for front-end and api
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format
at the back end mongodb converts json
data into a binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data
now all of these documents are stored in
a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data
this makes fetching of data extremely
efficient when compared to other
databases now you must be wondering
where exactly mongodb can be applied or
used so let me help you with that
several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things
mobile applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco
barclays and google among others readily
deploy mongodb as their database
management system
in this video i'm going to help you
install and set up mongodb on your
windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and you can see that the current version
is 4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your [ __ ] and the mongod applications
both are executable files now the
mongodb file or the application is the
daemon process now this is the
background process that make sure you
retrieve the data from the database
access the data so it does all the
background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file by doing this you
don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path
and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on
okay and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the [ __ ] file so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
[ __ ] server has been generated
and
with this you know that your in mongodb
has been successfully installed and your
server is up and running right so just
for confirmation let's see if there are
any databases and how much space they've
occupied so you can right now just types
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning
what mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile db so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a
traditional document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay nosql means
it doesn't says like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
heretical relationship using the single
records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema-less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized involvement
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql so it is completely into
the non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
uh you talk about
uh typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional rdbps
approach if you see there they are using
a complete table structure like they
talk about columns they talk about rows
and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents
so the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobile db installation works
and the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select depends
on which platform you have it and after
that you will be clicking on this
download
okay so it will get ready for if you are
from windows
i would say in this windows
you can select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip powered portion because it won't
start any mobo db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so
inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay another file which is available
called
mobo mobo d is to basically start a
mongodb server
and the mongodb mogo is actually the
client which will connect with the
mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment so once you are
inside this bin folder of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mogo so it
will get start as a client
okay since i'm using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the macbook so here to
start mongodb we have a very special way
to start with so here i'll start with my
terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongodb
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is the place where
your database will be starting and one
more important thing i forgot to mention
like
momoni would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
fold structure in place in your local
machine otherwise this is not going to
start
every time you start your mongodb
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db path
slash data db i hit enter you can see
now my mobile db is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now so here
i open
the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my
mongodb and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there inside
your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say you
simply db it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means you are in current
database name for simplydb
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created is last
time so how we can check this out we can
say
show
space
dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created up a database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now
when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the mongodb rule unless we
have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually in idb
message is called here it is called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you
like it is a document based database so
here every single record what you try to
insert it is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well we have to basically go and create
a new collection
okay so what you can say db dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say
the table is created and now when i try
to see same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.createcollection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this
particular functionality called create
collection i can directly use this
statement name called
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl student dot insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json-based structure and due to that
it goes with the key in value pairs
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert a
record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections
when i say show collections i can list
down those number of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language
which are there added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list down those
number of records which are added i say
fine and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i write this
command called sl student dot insert it
not only create a new collection for me
but also
insert the record into my
table also called a
collection that's where exactly it is
giving you the advantage when you want
the collections to be created along with
the data this is the way how you can
really do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db.create collection many people always
think about what is the significance of
having this db.create collection
look
db.createcollection is having its own
significance we never recommend this
technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbitor
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you are talking about let me try to
brief you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
i say
capped colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i'm going
to pass that is known is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i'm saying
5 2
4 and also we are saying 2 double 8 0
that is the size of 5mb and here we are
giving call max
colon
5.
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping
so what is that meaning is it is trying
to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5. clear and the collective
size of documents cannot be increased to
more than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of 5 records
the collective size of 5 document will
reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say db.create collection this option is
not possible when you're trying to use
this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document and second is called
embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
uh i would say the parent record as well
as the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we need to talk about
caller name
this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one i'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name
we are given the course name called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have a few more properties like in
course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property
and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address and address
we can say one more curly braces
and inside this address we can say city
giving the name called what
bangalore
another one we are using that is called
state
um
let me remove this state
colon
ke
okay and the third property we're using
that is called country
here is saying
i that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also you have option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobile db will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can override
i haven't provided any underscore id is
a property because this is a predefined
property associated with every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can override the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try with some
another record so the same record if i
try to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now records are added now
let me call find now you see this time
the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be given to you so this is
the first way of how the insert document
has been done will be telling you the
another ways where the other documents
are also added
okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in [ __ ] tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for var
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding the first
property called emp id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
you know the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id one and we just give the second
property called emp name
so emp id
i just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one
that is called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing and
once it is done you come down and say db
dot
new amp
dot
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my afb
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known called bulk
insert when you are inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what
your new emp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a book
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update
on any of my records how will i do this
now so we have a predefined functions
available name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call our new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay so what i will do i will say db.new
emp dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what were called emp name so we
say wherever the emp id is this i want
to change what the name how can i do
this now
very simple
uh
to perform this what i would like to do
now i want to basically add few more
records to give you some more better
idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just say four
i say five
is six
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find now we have
total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
as a emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new that name i want to change it
close this
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and there is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notices like
when you try to perform update
so what mobo dv does it starts from the
top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results
and that is something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a column name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi-color true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions
hit enter this time you can say it is
saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the moho tv and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about absurd upside is
a combinations of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
this point
yeah you see what multi-tool we have
used
now here
this
multi true is we're trying to update but
let's talk about something called
manager two
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there is one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi true
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we're using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
observe true
when i say upset rule so what happened
now
they say
and match 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you will be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager too
fine it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager 2 i will call qa
qa and here we are saying emp equal to
new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted at zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so mongodb
also helps you to perform the delete
part and how you'll be trying to add it
now let's try to understand here in my
code if i want to perform any delete
part i have this statement name called
db
dot
the option we are using it that is known
collection name emp
a new emp sorry
dot we have option number removed
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove we can see it is record removing
the first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin new is available
now in a similar way if i try to remove
the property call uh
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c
in third part we have seen update part
we have seen delete part we have seen
now it's time to basically fetch the
records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that let's see db
dot
new emp
dot
find clear now
so in fine you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now you can see it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now in a similar line if you really
don't want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name call
limit
to means only two records now you can
see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say emp name
okay and
using ascending order or descending
order so we can just say
minus one that's called descending order
okay
now you can see it is showing a
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
that is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property behalf on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order so
that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on their embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
uh let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db
dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i am talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say db dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like my outermost property name is
called what address so we are using this
option called
address
dot
dot
city
so we say
city are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here hit enter and
you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
[Music]
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than or whatever values you
would like to make it
is available and possible
okay
so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what 2 so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property okay so what's property
we're using emp id we are saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
jt
gc stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value call what one
fine
close this
run you can see you have received three
records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so called limit as i can say
find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me
try to take the property call file and
here we are providing emp
id
and then and we're using other curly
braces and we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details
i'm saying
inside so the property
six we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as called working with
indexing see mongodb is one of the most
popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
document which is huge document
in case if you would like to perform any
sort of indexing inside this how you
will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how will be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot
new emp
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me
now let me try to apply indexing without
indexing if i want to find a result what
outcome i'm gonna receive
so to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me
i'll be using this statement name called
tv
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution starts
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution stats will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
giving the name called
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was
hit enter and now you can see
a lot of details
are available with
me like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and returned one that means one result
is returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i ever got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you
have no indexing is available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied on your underscore id
db
dot
new emp
yeah db dot num p dot
when i say
db.newemp.getindex is a predefined
function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantages it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
new emp
dot
create index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is apply on
two properties if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
anyway
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one
see now earlier the number of document
examined were three but since this index
is applied notice telling me the total
number of document examined is one so
performance is certainly improved
so to search a document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is okay everybody so we have
already seen in our previous example how
we have applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i will be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db.collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here we are saying emp id
and in this emp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we are saying
minus one
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out
uh db dot
new m p dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot drop index
draw
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be
i would say the traditional name called
emp id no it has to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was three
okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in the previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen
how to utilize
uh indexing into our code now in our
next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobile db
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of
records are already added
now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation okay so aggregation is
nothing but a call aggregate like rdbms
if you see what we call aggregation
there so the unix command like you talk
about shell pipeline means the
possibility to execute an operation on
some input and use that output as an
input for the next command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of
functionalities are available which we
will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use a
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from the collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available which we will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains
the student name
okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to different sections
as you can see now it is a they belong
to the different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out with those students
who belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so
db.student.aggregate aggregate should be
always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a
hit enter and you can see now it lists
down all those students who belong to
the section a
okay very simple and straightforward
example now we would like to use the
second example so we want to find out
all the records
where the section is a and we are using
and operator
marks is greater than 80 there are so
many students who have a different marks
like 17 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks
colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than
colon
80.
okay
all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket in noun brackets
so
what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by
again curly braces again curly braces
again
square bracket
again round brackets
okay
let's see where it has gone wrong
so we are using this
db.student.agree will use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces
and we have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
this square bracket then curly braces
section a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon
80
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly braces square
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that
so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this
document i would like to selectively
take specific property
so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so
i just use this statement name called db
dot
student
okay dot
aggregate we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what you would like to use dollar
project and calling we are trying to use
student name
okay column
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the 1 as a digit that means it
is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying 1
comma i'm saying section
colon
one
okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is 0
that means the id will not be visible
here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if you want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is
a okay so here it will be the
combinations of match as well as the
project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name colon we're using one
comma
section colon one and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those
so the requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from
student collection where the section is
a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can
implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avgn
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taken place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out the
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so
here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar
group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this
underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about group this
is a compulsory field you need to have
it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
here curly braces
again
uh
dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have i want to
use in mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay
then and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of
records so hope you are clear about how
we utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
how we are basically taking this
marks in my application
fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
colon
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you're able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now okay so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform an
average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of student in each
section and total marks and average
marks as well as so total marks as well
as the average marks you want to get it
so how are you able to take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also
into our code how we have taken call
group underscore id section talking
about section
total marks with the sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say some marks
after that
we can just put curly braces and we can
just use
count
okay
and
after this
we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay
colon
one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say dollar avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with
mobile db mobile db is properly known
for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need
to install any software for this because
it is a building feature for the mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part okay so let's get started and talk
about how mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about the replication
you are replicating your data to where
to the multiple child so here in mobile
db we have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay
and
slaves
okay
master is one and there will be multiple
slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored and this is a master
which will be responsible to replicate
the data to all its childs when the
request comes due to that
in case if one particular
node fails so automatically the data
will be taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called [ __ ]
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobodb atlas database as a
service see this is a free
tool
it's the cloud environment where you
really don't need to install mobo db in
your local machine it is a cloud-based
mongodb support which is free to use
with a limited amount of space but yes
for the testing purpose it is the best
suitable
so i can start with the start free or
else i can say the login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mobile tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me okay so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and
8gb ram cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour
reason being because i already have a
cluster with me hence more than one
cluster is not allowed in a free tier
cluster so i have to cancel this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster
it will take a while minimum
two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you
and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there in a
crystal when you click on cluster zero
you can see now here we have a got
three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have called slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary and two will be
secondary
based on your package
whichever you have taken it you can
increase the number of nodes later on
but as a free i'm gonna get i will be
receiving total number of three nodes
available here
so records whichever will be stored
it will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when a cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now first setting is you have
to put it and remember the steps first
step will be your network access
so in network access you have to go
and you have to say add ip address and
in this add ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be
whitelisted otherwise what you can do
you can see here in my options i have
given
0.040 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user that already
some new users are created but it is
recommended that you to go and create a
new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password
as per your own convenience so new user
i'm going to create it is called
sl
okay
user and here we're giving call
uh
admin
one two three so sl user admin one two
three
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
and movement to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
there will be one option in call
collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there a lot many databases
are there so you can go back and create
some new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee like say create
now you can see sldm create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and uh once it is there ready
so remember slw
and employee i'll go back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass
so
since i already have a [ __ ] shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so we can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line but i need to
replace with this uh
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
well i'll selected this i open my
terminal
and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to correct for the [ __ ]
shell now
so
what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i say
as a user
i hit enter it will ask me the password
so i'm giving the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say
show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say db
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
um name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project 0 where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay so that's where exactly it works
fine for all of you
so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
fine
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted in this
particular tutorial we will help you to
connect your mongodb
with the front end that is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you this
connectivity where you can have the
mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the mongodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud
and we can have this connectivity with
our python which is running local to my
system so i show you what few important
things
one by one
so
why python mongodb we understand mongodb
is one of the most important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely called nosql database
okay and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how python and mongodb works
together
okay so you can
use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of
applications which can suits
to different type of ideas now here we
have one of the very very popular tool
available name called pi [ __ ]
so pi [ __ ] is actually the python
library which is the kind of uh driver
through which you will be able to
connect with your mongodb and perform
basic operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment
with cluster in one of the very very
popular tool that is known as called
mongodb atlas so we'll be opening our
website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb
atlas
i search for mongodb atlas that is
basically the mongodb
where i called database as a service
i'll be selecting the first option
and go to the start free because it's
gonna offer you by default some 500 db
of free space
i say sign up with google
going ahead and selecting this
okay i say accept
and say submit
okay so it's starting up now
it'll ask you about a few things i would
rather say to select escape
and continue
well it will ask you about which
environment you would like to take so
i like to take this shared cluster i say
create cluster
now here it will take a while to get
yourself ready for you can see it is
offering the sandbox of having five
columbia free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default custom
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but let it be y d
for cluster zero i'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so i tell you what this
cluster is going to give you
by default two child and one parent so
called a one master and two
uh child nodes where your cluster will
get ready
so
you really don't need to set up any kind
of cluster in your local environment and
that is the best environment i would
suggest for
most of your development where your time
reduced
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting ready so once the
cluster is ready you will be seeing some
options
where
will help you to create the clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment
so in this environment you will see
there are some options they have given
you one by one
build up your cluster create a first
database user
add an ip address multiple options they
are telling you now so how to set up so
the first build of the cluster which we
have anyways done
next is called create your first
database user so select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and
i'm going to create a first new database
user and new database user
given there is a name for admin
let's keep very simple username and
password admin
one two three so admin and win123
yeah same
and same add user
now you can see the user is
created now let's go back to the next
option
it's telling me the network access now
go here
and say
sorry
now say add ip address
and
i'll say allow access from anywhere
so that i can take it from anywhere
i say confirm
now it is telling me about a progress i
select this
now tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so i select this
and inside this i'll be selecting this
called collections
okay
and
it's getting
ready
so it is giving me some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data i'll say
add my own data give the database name
sl demo
give the collection name emp or employee
remember
database name sl demo or i can better
give the name called srdb
sldb and employ i say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it
so i think
we are all set
with this environment
okay
well once it is ready your collection is
also ready
i'll go back and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then i'll be
clicking on this option call
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect
so it will say correct for the [ __ ]
shell or it will say connect with your
application connect using [ __ ] compass
i'll select the python
python version
3.11 or later so certainly i'll be using
those version only
okay
and
in this i'm having this
so i will be using this to connect with
my back end
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster
everyone so we are all ready now with
our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later
so here if i just go back and check
i have a god
3.8.5 which is python 3 version which is
available
so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's say 3.11 or
later we can say 3.6
or later so there'll be no much
difference if i just see
even if i just talk about 3.4 there's
some change but here 3.6 or later
it is same so i have a 3.8.5
okay so
i can use the same option
so here in my
vs core editor i am using for my
development so here's a simple demo dot
pi i have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
i'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so i just go back and say
uh demo
py or i can say uh
[Music]
py
demo
dot py
okay
and here if i want to go back and start
working on the development remember one
thing we need first dependency called pi
[ __ ]
okay what i need pi men [ __ ] and for
this we have already installed this
dependency here
sometime back this is how you need to
install
okay so we have this statement name
called what
pip installed by mongol
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay
so
that's what we have taken this is
installed by [ __ ] so if you just see
you can go back and start
developing this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this
step number one you need to always say
import
number one the one dependence which
we've installed is called buy [ __ ]
so
you can just say p by m o n g o
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import pi [ __ ]
from
here we are saying pi [ __ ]
okay
pie [ __ ]
and we're also saying import
[ __ ] client
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay after that we would like to go back
and use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
[ __ ] client and here i'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line
i just take it
go back
and here
i'm pasting it
now here
i have to basically replace this
password with admin 123
okay and we are all set
okay
now
once it is ready
we can go ahead and define db
equal to
cluster
and provide
which database you're talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call
sltb so i can just use the same sltp
there
and accordingly i can use
which collection i'm connecting it to so
accordingly i can go back and insert a
record okay everybody so i can see i
have got this
file with me going forward i have to
tell see if this is what exactly the
connection url you have received now if
you define which database you are
working on
let me say tp equal to
cluster and we have to provide
in
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to
db and here we just give the name call
employee
that was our collection name
so once it is ready then i have to
basically perform some insert operation
so i just say post
okay it's just a name equal to
and here
we just provide the properties
like i would say name
so
you know to the json-based database so i
can just use the name
i say
and once again
you can just say
email
and
say
email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
i have now i want to insert so i can
certainly say
collection dot because i want to insert
only one record you can see i have open
functions coming up collections dot
insert one and pass
post
isn't parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so i'll be running this with python 3
py mobile demo dot py
hit enter
now it's done let's confirm
here into my code i will just go back
and check
here inside my
applications i can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up
here okay so these records are nothing
but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay so fantastic so first example is
working perfectly fine how we can have
the records coming from the python and
insert it there like that i can have as
my number of records i can
add it
so how we can basically add if i want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here in case if i
want to add more than one records so i
can just use call post one
i copy this url
and paste it below and i say pause to
i say
i'm saying
email
i'mma want to at the rightmail.com and
rather than saying insert one
i can use
insert many and inside this i'll be
using this
square brackets
and pass
post
post one corner
post two
that's it
okay so let's change the little name
because it's already there
let's insert
yep records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
well now we have a total number of three
records are available
yeah there we go so records are added
perfect so like this you can have
as my number of records you can
basically add it in a similar one the
way we have basically used this i can
also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what
i'll go here
the way we have added this so
in this i'll just
these records which are added inside my
application i would not execute this
rather
i would like to go back and say
and
now they are basically commented now
and
in fact i would like to use this also
okay i will go here
and
find results
results equal to
same collection
dot
find if i want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
[Music]
okay
so let me say print
and turns
results
okay let's run this
okay so it'll print what
the results for me
okay
so
it is just printing what the cursor
object for me saying hey this is what a
record is available to me we can also
change in case if we do not think the
correct result is coming up we can also
go back and
we can use some alternative option that
is called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
with this for i can say result
in
results
and
print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get
the details with you
okay so what you can do you can run this
code again
i forgot to put this
semicolon here
or
we need to check
well that was my
requirement was so i'm having this
let's try to run this
well i got my result and this is what
the detail which i have available to me
so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code in this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want id or else
if you want name
you can basically pick that up
okay so if i just want that
id
the only id is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this fine
now in a similar line you can also have
the option available because see when we
used to talk about confine it gets me
lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this loop
but in case if you want to fetch the
individual records
i'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use fine you can
just
use find one
so what we can do is rather than using
find
i can also use one more option called
fine
one and for which
i can come back
just remove this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file i can use find
underscore you can see this option
called find one
here we talk about
which are the properties you want to
skip and which of the properties you
want
so i can just use this option called
underscore
idle
okay colon
zero okay i just remove this
undersquared zero and here
just print what
results
that's it let's run
so that will try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that id which you overwritten it
will certainly not found it depends on
what you would like to take so if i just
say
is having some issues but no problem but
you know it very well how it basically
takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity
to talk about delete
so for which what i will do is this i
just want to uncomment it
okay and i would like to insert some
records here
so here i want to
add the id by my own
with name
so we already have this name
email
i have it i would like to use underscore
id
okay
so
let me have this property underscore id
colon one zero one
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
am using
102
name and everything
it will be taken let me say
user1
here we try to say
user two
okay so collections dot many result file
one i'm just deleting it all
and let's try to
execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so i have some records with id one
zero one and zero two now here
i just delete this
and perform some actions here
here we say
results
equal to
collection
dot
delete
see the options are available delete one
and delete money it totally depends on
what you really want
okay so if i just talk about call delete
one it will be only deleting one record
delete many means where the matching
records are available to delete it
fine so i'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
matched cause quite possible names
sometimes match or whatever it is first
then delete many
so the option is up to you now how you
want so the selected name you have to
offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is so that
will be offering me but there's also one
option available where you would like to
delete everything
are we clear so if you're planning to
delete everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete
underscore menu
let's check
great all records are deleted
so as i told you earlier also so delete
many means what it will delete all the
records whichever are present in your
code now
clear in a similar one if i want to
perform insert
so you remember about we have an option
called what
insert many
and here
you would like to pass
post one
host two let's execute
so it will add
the records inside this
okay
and next time what i want to perform
after adding this record i would like to
perform the update part
okay
so
what i really wanted my update let's
take a look update means certain
properties i'm looking forward to we get
updated
okay so
in case if i want to check with the
record has to be updated i would first
go and check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update part
here
i just
say collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see update one here very
simple functionality
here you will go
and tell which id would like to perform
an update
so i say underscore
id
colon
which i do want to consider i'm saying
one zero one
okay
and what else
so i just use another curly braces and i
say
sorry
dollar
set
and after this
i use this colon
use the curly braces
name
okay
and
use whatever you want to use it so
suppose there is a user one i'm saying
users
one two three
okay let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 1v3 is updated
perfect
so
your code is absolutely working fine so
you talk about either insert you talk
about what
update
you talk about anything it works so
insert update one
delete one
insert one as the name suggests they'll
be taking care about inserting updating
and deleting one one records but the
moment you use many they'll be
performing multiple records so this is a
very simple way like how the python will
connect with your mongodb in this video
we're going to learn about the
differences between mysql and mongodb
now i'm sure you must have heard about
these database management systems
but do you exactly know what set them
apart
don't worry i'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there is no set schema to define
how the data is being stored in the
database
this causes lesser data migrations
but what exactly is mysql then
now mysql is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented
mysql is a relational database system
now this uses something called as a
structured query language and this is
used to access data which is stored in
the form of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and sql is developed and maintained by
oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between mysql and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now mysql requires you to define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data in the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier mysql requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database now this schema is crucial in
case of mysql
on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
mysql uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set etc
in case of mongodb it supports a json
query language to work with data next up
is foreign keys
now mysql supports the usage of foreign
keys now if you don't know what exactly
a foreign key is then sql uses foreign
keys to link one table to another now
these foreign keys make data retrieval
easy especially when there are multiple
tables interlinked with one another in
case of mongodb there's no support for
foreign keys
next up is replication
now mysql supports the master slave and
the master master replication in this
setup data set from one master database
server can be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb it uses something
called as sharding now sharding allows
partitioning of data across multiple
servers using a shard key
don't worry if you're not able to
understand these concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
concepts in detail
next up is scalability now sql database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources
while vertical scaling refers to scaling
by adding more power like for example
cpu or ram
moving ahead let's look at performance
now mysql is optimized for high
performance joins across multiple tables
while mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about community support some of
the popular github repositories on mysql
currently are mysql js mysql and then
there's mysql server and at the time of
writing there were about 222 000
repositories on github with 7 million
comments for mysql in case of mongodb
few popular github repositories are
mongodb slash [ __ ] and doctrine slash
mongodb and at the time of writing there
were about 177 000 repositories with
about 923 000 comments according to
google trends mysql is largely used
compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well
if your application requires multi-row
transactions
like for example in accounting system
then a relational database would be more
ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for
real-time analytics content management
internet of things mobile applications
and so on
also mysql is a great choice if you have
structured data and need a traditional
relational database
in case of mongodb
it is an ideal choice if you have an
unstructured set of data so you could
pick your choice and if you're partial
towards one dbms let us know in the
comment section below as to why you like
that particular dbms
nodejs is a far javascript runtime
environment but it does not support
request handling functions http methods
or serving files
so express js comes into the picture
express makes the node.js code easier
as express provides a wide range of
features to develop both web and mobile
applications it is used to build single
page multipage and hybrid page web
applications as express is written in
javascript it is very easy to understand
for the developers who know javascript
until now express is the most popular
framework of node.js
you must have heard about mean stack in
web development right
where e stands for express.js
it is a backend part of mean stack
it manages routing http method sessions
error handling etc
let's see what express js is
express js is a node.js framework
designed to build api's web applications
cross platform mobile apps
quickly and easily
it is very high performance
fast lightweight and unopenated that is
there is no structural way to write a
code express does not force you to write
a code in a fixed manner
express js is used as a server-side
scripting language let's see the need
for express js but before that let me
give you an example
if you have to write a rest api using
the core modules of node.js and the same
using the framework express.js you will
realize that with the help of express it
will take 5 to 10 times less code and
time
that was the reason behind creating
express js framework for nodejs
express js is time efficient
fast money efficient
very easy to learn and asynchronous
let's see the features of express.js
for server side development with the
features of node.js xps saves a lot of
time
middleware middleware is a request
handler that has access to the
application's request respond cycle
routing this refers to how an
application's endpoints urls respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
dynamic content on the web pages by
creating html templates on the server
debugging express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
let's see the advantages of express.js
express is unopenated and we can
customize it and use it as per our needs
as it is written in javascript a single
language is used for frontend and
backend development express is fast to
link it with databases like mysql
mongodb etc
let's see the disadvantages the
disadvantage of xps.js is that there is
no structural way to organize things
sometimes the code becomes
non-understandable
there are so many issues with callbacks
the error messages that will come are
very challenging to understand
now we'll see the companies that are
using express.js
the major companies are ibm
uber ebay paypal accenture fox sports
netflix linkedin
as per the nlip.com there are more than
34 300 companies that are using
express.js now
i think you guys have a brief idea about
express as it is a lightweight framework
that gives functionalities to make
node.js easy
expressjs is trending so much because it
is helping so many developers to save
their time it is so awesome that most of
the companies are moving towards it
if you know javascript and node.js the
framework expresses what you should know
to strengthen your coding skills
now here
you'll find downloads
you can download node from here
and install it
but if you find any difficulties
downloading node.js you can click on the
link in the right corner to see how to
download node.js
now
let's see the version for node to verify
here i am using visual studio code you
can go and search it and simply download
vs code
after opening your visual studio code
it will look like this
here
you will find a terminal click on it
the terminal window will open
here we will write node
hyphen b
this will show us the latest version of
node.js
now we need to update the npm which is
node packet manager this bundle consists
of all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes to do
that
npm install npm globally
nvm
install
npm
hyphen
globally
this will download all the npm packages
globally now let's create express
for that first we need to create a
separate folder where we will keep all
the modules and files of express.js
let's clean this
tls
you can open the terminal by clicking on
the shortcut also by pressing ctrl and
backtick
that will open the terminal for you
let's make a folder
mk dir
this is a command that is used to create
a folder on the terminal
then we will write our file name i will
write express
by
simply learn
enter
here you can see the file name expressed
by simple line has been created
you can also click here
and enter your file name
m.js
press enter
as you can see a new file has been
created now we need to install a package
manager that is npm
we will write a npm command
open your terminal again
write a command
npm
init
enter
enter
version enter description and
description you can write express
tutorial
by
simply learn enter
enter
enter
hit repository if you have your git
repository you can add yours enter
enter
author
we learn
license enter press yes
after this
you can see npm created a json file
now we will finally install express.js
we will write
npm
install
express
enter
now as you can see our express is
installed in our system
let's open the app.js that we have
created earlier
now
we will create a express application
with the help of express functions
that we can do
by requiring the express modules let's
create our first program
first
constant
express
require
express
in this line we are requiring the
express module
const
and name equals to
function
express
dot get
to get the file
request response
to get the request and the response
of the
user
function
we will need to pass callback function
here
let's write
response send
this message
will be shown
in the server welcome
to
welcome to simply learn
now here
we will write a port number where the
message will be shown to us
at dot lesson
4 000
you can write anything
here also
we are passing the callback function
dot
console.log
in console log we will see the message
in the console
listening to port
number
4000
close this line
save this
let's run it open your terminal new
terminal
now to run this file
we need to go to the express
folder cd
express
by simply learn
we are now in a simply lan folder
now
easiest way is to write the file name
write node
space
the file name app.js
enter
now you can see it is printing our
message listening to port 4000
now we will see a message on the server
open your chrome
type localhost 4000
press enter
and here we go a message is successfully
displayed welcome to simply learn
get in post method are the standard http
request used to create rest apis
get in post methods are used to send and
receive significant amount of data
the client sends a request in the form
of json file and with the help of http
requests which are get post and other
methods it will go to the server and
then the server sends back the response
to the client in the form of a message
to tell what happened to the request
that was sent to the server
now
expressjs get method
get is a method that is used to request
data from the server but mainly this
method is used to read data
to handle get request in express is
pretty straightforward
get requests are to be cached and
remains in the browser history and
that's why the get method is not used
for sensitive data
to get the data we add parameters in the
url and get data in response
get method is more efficient and popular
than the post method
now we'll see expressjs post method
host method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data
this method is used to communicate with
large amount of data
the post method is secure because the
data is passed in a request body and not
visible in the url and the user is not
able to bookmark it mostly we use get
method only but when we want to send a
sensitive data we use post method
now we will see how to get the post and
get methods work
now open your visual studio code
i have already installed node and
express if you haven't install it then
you can click on the right corner of
this video to get the setup done
coming back to express get and post
methods
now what i have done here is i have
created a basic expressjs app
const app require express this will
install all our express modules
now
first we will write our get method
so let's start
first we will write get method
then we will initialize
how it will be called
will write get
this
question
we'll create
function request parameters
request and response
then we'll write the flat arrow function
in this
we will send a response
to the server
hello
this is
let's
i have not initialized the brackets
let's see what i have not done oh
forgot to write this
now let's just save this file
we will run this file
open your terminal
and write node
dot
and
i think i have done something wrong
let's again open the terminal
write node
dot
so it is showing server is successfully
running on port 4000
now we will open our chrome
and write localhost
enter
as i have told you earlier
this needs a parameter so we'll
initialize here
get
request
hello this is successful get request
so a request method is working fine
now
we'll go back to the post method and see
how it goes
app
dot post
request
response
response and
just like this only
just
post
hello
this is
successful
post
twist
now we'll run save this first
and then run it in the terminal
yes
node
dot server is running on 4000
we have to write this
so first copy from here only
open your terminal
and here we can write
post quest enter
so what you can see here is it can't get